[Musique]
la lutte contre le racisme
l'antisémitisme et la haine anti lgbt
lesbienne gay bi et trans on en parle
avec vous frédéric potier dans ce cas
dit bonjour bonjour vous êtes le délégué
interministériel de passage chez nous
sur cette question au moment où les
grands partis politiques français ont
annoncé leur participation aujourd'hui
aux manifestations contre
l'antisémitisme d'antisémitisme qui en
martinique n'est peut-être pas le délit
le plus observé chez nous mais les
insultes racistes sont une réalité entre
noirs et blancs
il y a bel et bien des formes de racisme
lié surtout à la couleur de la peau oui
bien sûr il ya différentes
manifestations du racisme il ya
différentes manifestations de haine et
il faut tout les combattre le racisme
l'antisémitisme la haine anti lgbt qu'on
appelle plus communément l'homophobie
c'est le sens de ma mission en tant que
délégué interministériel si le sens de
ma venue ici en martinique
comment l'expliquer que ce soit une
réalité au moment où les échanges font
de plus en plus nombreux
on est ici aujourd'hui demain on est
ailleurs ça se passe tellement vite on
est confronté à bas toutes ses facettes
de notre vie et vous avez parfaitement
raison il ya une forme de paradoxe on a
une société qui est plus ouverte
globalement plus tolérante les gens
voyagent beaucoup plus et en même temps
cette plus grande tolérance elle crée
aussi des replis c'est très clair sur la
question de l'homophobie des jeunes
hommes des jeunes femmes peuvent se
donner des marques d'affection dans la
rue et ça crée aussi cette plus grande
visibilité des rejets et c'est serge est
là qu il faut combattre c'est ce que
j'essaye de faire avec tout un tas de
partenaires avec des associations que
j'ai pu rencontrer hier que je
rencontrerai encore cet après-midi lieu
en martinique l'état je veux souligner
ici l'implication très forte du préfet
du recteur du procureur de la république
et évidemment tous les partis politiques
qui ont aussi un combat culturel
politique à mener vous avez parlé de ce
combat qu'il faut mener au niveau
culturel parce que c'est inscrit dans
l'histoire tout simplement certaines
choses par exemple que celui qui est
clair de peau et potentiellement celui
qui a l'argent et le pouvoir est dans
l'autre sens quand on est un peu plus
foncé on n'y arrive pas au regard des
tout simplement tour de soins
mais permet de voir qu'il ya plutôt 50
mille nuances dans de telles
affirmations
oui bien sûr il ya beaucoup de préjugés
ya beaucoup de clichés et de stéréotypes
on le voit hélas aussi en métropole en
ce moment sur la question de
l'antisémitisme avec les liens qui sont
faits entre les juifs et l'argent le
juif est de pouvoir
donc il faut combattre tout ça ça passe
beaucoup par l'éducation et c'est pour
ça que je serai dans quelques instants
dans le nord de la martinique pour
assister à une séance de théâtre forum
avec des jeunes qui ont travaillé sur
ces questions
on va y revenir à cette expérience avec
les jeunes oserait tout à l'heure à sa
pierre mais ce racisme et alimentent
également par par des faits les
antillais qui pend en france par exemple
pour leurs études ne se sentent pas
considérés comme des français à part
entière ou entièrement à part le débat
se poursuit éternellement parce qu'on
juge encore une fois sur la couleur de
la peau et comment on peut faire
lorsqu'on a sensibilisé lorsqu'on a
éduqué lorsqu'on a formulé n'y arrive
pas mais c'est un travail sans fin il
n'y a pas de recette miracle n'a pas de
baguette magique on va pas faire
disparaître des siècles et des siècles
de préjugés qui sont solidement ancrés
dans les mentalités
par contre il ya un combat à mener et ce
combat en métropole on le mène aussi
avec quelqu'un comme jean marc mormeck
qui est délégué interministériel à
l'égalité des chances des français
d'outre-mer et ode à la question de la
couleur de peau il ya aussi d'autres
types de discriminations moi j'ai été
très frappée en cette rentrée que nous
avons connu en septembre octobre à
l'université de beaucoup de jeunes
ultramarins qui en métropole avec des
difficultés pour se loger
parce que la caution de bancaire du papa
de la maman était en martinique était en
guadeloupe
je parle même pas des territoires plus
lointaines pacifique où on a des comptes
qui sont pas forcément en euros mais ça
c'est des choses très aiguë des choses
très concrètes contre lesquelles on
combat avec jean marc mormeck donc cédé
sensibilisation de grands réseaux
immobiliers cédés couilles et c'est
parfois de la sixième question
d'éducation c'est une question de
connaissances de savoirs la martinique
c'est la france jusqu'à preuve du
contraire
et pourquoi on est considérés comme des
étrangers mais moi moi j'ai pas de
réponse à vous donner là dessus il ya
des clichés qui sont tenaces évidemment
la martinique c'est évidemment la france
n'est pas un préfet la république qui va
vous dire linverse et c'est d'ailleurs
un beau visage de la france gt comme à
chaque fois que je viens en martinique
sur la tombe d'aimé césaire
on a ce message là qui manie sont à ce
message du métissage on a ce message de
société multiculturelle mais il faut
faire le constat qu'il ya aussi des
discriminations et ces discriminations
il faut les combattre par le droit
lorsqu'un jeune martiniquais en
métropole se voient refuser une un
logement une location
parce que ça que son bancaire n'est pas
bonne c'est une discrimination c'est
illégal
c'est dans la loi depuis 2007 2017
pardon et donc ça doit être sanctionné
et là il faut mieux faire appliquer
cette loi c'est ça l'enjeu il y à un
racisme anti blanc certains certaines
certains hexagone hall des bleus déplore
ici également vous en avez entendu
parler
oui bien sûr pas plus tard qu'hier lors
des échanges avec un certain nombre de
citoyens d'associations
moi je combats vraiment toutes les
manifestations de racisme et le racisme
anti blanc en est un
même c'est quelque chose de plutôt
marginal en métropole je ne prononcerai
pas sur forcément sur la martinique mais
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
sanctionner moi j'avais été amenés à
saisir la justice par exemple pour un
clip de rap ou le chanteur chantait il
faut tuer les blancs il faut tuer les
bébés blanc et donc il ya une audience
au tribunal de paris à quelques semaines
et on attend la sanction et je suis
persuadé qu'elle sera forte
il ya des signaux très forts qui ont été
envoyés en parler de la législation par
exemple comme les quotas la télévision
de noir sur les écrans de couples homos
dans les films séries et fictions ça n'a
pas marché finalement tout ça suis moi
je crois que ça marche honnêtement je
crois que ça marche ça prend du temps
évidemment mais quand les séries télé
vous avez des couples de jeunes femmes
lesbiennes ou lorsque vous avez des
personnalités qui affichent leur
homosexualité je crois que ça joue quand
même sur les représentations
moi je suis très frappé de quelque chose
je me suis toujours dit que l'élection
de barack obama devait beaucoup au fait
que dans une série télé qui s'appelait
24 heures je crois bien le président est
noir je crois que ça a beaucoup préparé
quatre cinq ans avant les mentalités à
cette évolution politique et en même
temps il y à certains qu'ils aient il y
en a trop que ce soit en parlant des
noirs que ce soit par un des couples
homos exposées ainsi dans les séries
dans les films moi je crois pas oui je
crois pas ouais donc ce matin vous vous
rendez au lycée victoire à nice à saint
pierre quel sera votre mode opératoire
face à ces jeunes des adolescents ce
sont des adultes en formation
oui alors je vais surtout pour voir ce
qu'on engageait les équipes pédagogiques
sur place parce que moi en tant que
délégué un tamis siège le pilote une
politique publique mais je me repose
beaucoup sur des acteurs de terrain des
associations des services de l'état et
donc là il ya une initiative assez
originale qui a été engagé par le
rectorat de la martinique avec un
certain nombre de professeurs pour
parler de cette question là pas de
manière trop condescendante outre
officiel mais plutôt avec l' usage du
théâtre avec l' usage de l'expérience de
la vie donc c'est ça que je vais
observer puis après j'ai une séance de
formation avec des équipes éducatives
sur ces questions ne risque pas d'être
perçue d'être vu comme à bien un adulte
qui vient faire la leçon
non c'est justement ce que j'ai vite à
chaque fois moi je beaucoup
d'interventions je me tiens au fond de
la classe et j'observe et je regardais
j'essaye d'en tirer des conclusions sur
la façon dont nous devons mener cette
politique publique à travers des
financements à travers des soutiens et
moi je veux d'ailleurs ici rendre
hommage à tous les bénévoles associatifs
ou les enseignants qui sur le terrain
même ce combat pour les valeurs et mène
ce combat pour la tolérance
quel est le poids de ce racisme
concernant l'homophobie
qu'est ce que vous avez comme remonter
ici chez nous je crois que c'est un
tabou alors moi je veux pas là encore
jugés ou stigmatiser mais je crois que
le poids des traditions le poids de la
religion est extrêmement forte en
martinique comme dans d'autres
territoires en d'ailleurs des antilles
plus plus qu ici qu'ailleurs peut-être
sur cet aspect là plus ici qu'en
métropole sur le poids de la religion
oui c'est ce que j'ai cru comprendre
hier des échanges avec un certain nombre
de personnalités
mais là encore il n'y a pas de fatalisme
il n'y a pas de deux choses impossibles
à faire moi je crois que chacun doit
avoir la possibilité de vivre pleinement
son orientation sexuelle son identité de
genre et qui dit que ces personnes n'ont
pas à subir des menaces pour ça
lorsqu'on nombre sexuelle est ce qu'il
faut absolument l'avouer est ce qu il
faut faire son coming out
chacun vit sa vie comme il le souhaite y
a pas d'injonctions à faire un coming
out simplement les gens qui souhaitent
vivre très paisiblement l'orientation
sexuelle et de manière publique ils
doivent pouvoir le faire c'est tout est
sens et cela sans menace sans
discrimination sans pression c'est ça
l'enjeu l'enjoué pas de dicter un
comportement qui viendrait de quelque
part l'enjeu le dire vous devez tout
simplement pouvoir vivre votre vie
amoureuse puisqu'on parle beaucoup de
rotations sexuelle mais c'est tout
simplement des relations amoureuses
abord parce qu on parle d'amour vous
avez rencontré les autorités de police
et de justice hier qu'en est il ressorti
d'abord une difficulté à recenser et
avoir des plantes
on voit là qu'il ya d'abord un tabou
allait porter plainte dans un
commissariat ou une gendarmerie
c'est peut-être plus difficile en
martinique qu'en métropole parce qu on
est sur un territoire où tout le monde
se connaît pardonnez moi l'expression
mais il ya un peu de ça ce de dons ce
dont il s'agit et donc du coup le fait
de déposer plainte
en quelque sorte on révèle aussi son
orientation amoureuse et donc du coup on
a effectivement très très peu de plans
de 3,15 à u2 pour l'année 2018 ce qui
est effectivement très très très peu et
à au delà de cette qui sort au delà de
l'homophobie oui de l'homophobie parlant
je parle de l'eau pays et au delà de
cette question du dépôt de plainte est
aussi la question de la formation des
gendarmes et des policiers moi c'est
quelque chose que je fais beaucoup je
vais dans toutes les écoles de police de
gendarmerie pour parler de cette
question là pour aider les policiers les
gendarmes à mieux comprendre ce qu'ils
doivent faire
ceux qui doivent poser comme question
avec délicatesse avec discrétion parce
que lorsqu'on dépose plainte pour un cas
d'homophobie
on n'a pas envie non plus d'étaler sa
vie privée de devant tout le monde
mais il faut pouvoir aussi caractérisé
cette agression ou cette insulte lorsque
c'est le cas et c'est la discussion que
j'avais avec le pro kurde la république
donc ce dont nous avons contenu c'est
que la délégation que j'anime puisse
revenir ici pour former des policiers
des gendarmes des magistrats et des
enseignants la dernière question puisque
nous sommes pris par le temps le racisme
générationnel c'est une réalité
également on est trop jeune henry trop
vieux n'avez pas votre place etc
je sais pas écoutez moi que j'ai souvent
été le plus jeune dans le corps
préfectoral
ça a changé il ya quelques semaines
parfois je suis le plus vieux d'autres
groupes de personnes
je suis pas sûr que ce soit ça la
principale de crispation du moment merci
d'avoir été avec nous frédéric à petit
on rappelle que vous êtes ce délégué
interministériel contre le racisme et
que vous rendez tout à l'heure à sa
pierre au litige au lycée victor allis
et merci d'avoir été ce matin dans son
caddie bonne journée merci
[Musique]